Carl's so nice to see you again before
we go any further I'd like to ask a
question of you and the audience sure
how many people here today at twelve
o'clock coming down for breakfast fell
down a flight of stairs and landed in
the foyer
on his back raise your hand no you did
you fell all the way down first of all
why you eating breakfast at 12:00
that's my first question
we'll get to your terrible injury I was
really a lunch that was a lunch okay all
right but yes I'm going down I said yeah
you knew that you couldn't afford to get
hurt because you had to make disappear
and nothing hurts nothing hurts why I
fell down and didn't get hurt I'm not
kidding when I was about 30 years old an
icy stairway I was going for a walk
around in nourishes and nourish shell
right and I know with the Bronx I fell
and hurt my back and the therapist said
do not get out of bed until you do the
series of Spears's
every morning stretches every single
morning but while you're still on the
mattress in the bed yeah he said if you
do anything else you go London you'll
not do so for 50 years I do these
stretches and the very by the way this
book is called a graphic diary and I
look through it it's fascinating it's
taking you through an entire day yeah
there's a lot of great stories in there
as well it's a whole day of your life
you show these stretches that you do and
the reason I listen to you is that you
are 94 whenever I see you you're the
sharpest person in the room you there's
still the funniest person in the room
and then you can fall down a flight of
stairs and here it is yeah
here it is this is the piece of the
[Applause]
why are you wearing a diaper
it's a pair of shorts okay it's a pair
of shorts oh my god you've got looks
pretty sexy right there I think that was
on a bill that's on the Billboard yeah
oh this is the boot look at your face in
this one now these two things yeah to do
this at 94 and stretch this four and put
your legs in that position I swear that
is the reason I was able to fall down
and by the way I'll be 95 next week next
one I think anybody watching right now
is going to get this book look at those
exercises and do them because you're the
I'm not kidding right it's not you can
fall I don't want to ever fall down
stairs again but I know I can do it now
so you're not recommending people know
you can get this book by using your
device and calling random dot-com random
content dot-com and if you ask me to
personalize it I will personalize you
can get that
[Applause]
you